but now here's the thing so both your
kids they're grown up now with that yeah
but when your daughter was starting to
date were you a relaxed fob
can you imagine ding dong in the door of
the did Sean Penn were you nice to the
suitors well when my my daughter waited
till about I guess it was Shu 16 when
the first one came to the door so that
was 16 years of waiting I'd been fairly
permissive with her she she had a lot to
trust you know going out with friends
and so on but this was not her night
this was my night and so he came to the
door she was ready then I had to explain
to her before I would answer the door
that she was not ready to go upstairs
and she tried to you know fluff that off
and I said no her name's Dylan I said
Dylan I will not let you go out with him
if I don't get this moment so you know
what she said oh my god dad and went
upstairs with a red face and so then I
went to the door and I opened it quickly
yeah mr. pen and I said no no no call me
Shawn that's your car yeah nice you're
not gonna drive drunk with my daughter
are you
no sir no call me Shawn oh yeah yes sir
Shawn he says no I won't drive good good
listen I'd prefer you get her back early
but I want you guys have a good time you
know and but the main thing whatever
time you do get her home whatever you do
with her while you're out I'm gonna do
with you when you get her home
but they home quite early well if the
thing was he he laughed and what I
thought was a nervous laughter with me
but it was laughing at me he was
three-time mixed martial arts champion
of his age category in California so the
whole threat was pretty human
I'll just draw a mustache on earth
little French curly mustache and then I
just let energy goes off and she forgets
about it I forget about did you enjoy
them
[Applause]